caillassage insulte aux sentiments nos
révoltes d'incompréhension et même coup
de poing moi c'est un ras le bol des
décennies que les sapeurs-pompiers
dénonce les agressions qu'ils subissent
au quotidien en 1988 par exemple ce
lieutenant racontait son attaque au
fusil de chasse lors d'une intervention
à mentir points comme ça sur des gens
surtout lorsqu'on vient porter secours
alors j'appelle ça des fous dans les
années 90 la contestation des soldats du
feu commence à s'organiser au sein des
brigades française un cri d'alarmé lancé
au travers de compétition et deux
marches silencieuses comme ici à lyon en
bien sûr c'est notre travail bien sûr
que comme la police comme les
sapeurs-pompiers et bien on est là pour
ça fait partie de notre métier et je
lire non pas n'importe quel prix c'est
ce que je veux dire c'est ce que nous
voulons tous dire aujourd'hui et dans le
silence et la dignité surtout un malaise
exprimé cette année là dans une lettre
ouverte adressée au président jacques
chirac le chef de l'état y répondait
mais sans annonce le 18 septembre 1999
au congrès national des sapeurs pompiers
ouvriers employés paysans artisans qui
prennent sur leur temps pour se former
et intervenir incarne le meilleur de la
société française le courage le
dévouement les solidarités
traditionnelles le sens des
responsabilités au prij le c'est de bien
des sacrifices nous gratitude qui ne
suffira pas à apaiser la colère des
pompiers français en 2005
les soldats du feu dénonçait encore le
manque d'action des pouvoirs publics
n'est ce pas complet nous sommes un
service public et les pouvoirs publics
doivent prendre leurs responsabilités
quand il s'agit d une agression s'est
passé d'un membre du service public doit
y aura des sanctions derrière mais
depuis le nombre de sapeurs pompiers
agressés continue d'augmenter en 2008
ils étaient 8 199
dix ans plus tard ils sont 3411 soit
presque quatre fois plus alors pour
faire face à cette violence quotidienne
les écoles de pompiers mettent leurs
élèves en situation incendies de
voitures gaz lacrymogènes émeutes
urbaines
dans ce scénario tout est fait pour
compliquer le travail des pompiers
passent à la grève inédite des soldats
du feu depuis juin 2019
le ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner fait des propositions parmi
elles
l'expérimentation de caméras piétons sur
les pompiers pour dissuader les
agresseurs potentiels
[Musique]